hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the greek gift
sacrifice this is one of the most common
bishop sacrifices that you'll see in
chess definitely one that you need to
understand
knowing when you can and cannot attack
your opponent's king there's lots of
different variations that can arrive
at a greek gift sacrifice we'll go over
one
it's from the french defense pawnee four
pawn e6
pawn here to d4 and then after d5
knight to c3 pretty common development
here knight to f6
pawn push forward to attack the knight
knight swings back here to
d7 knight to f3 continuing to develop
for white here bishop
to b4 getting the dark square bishop
involved into the game before they
castle on the king side at some point
bishop here to d3 preparing to castle on
the king side and then the move which is
a huge mistake for black but it is
castle on
the king side and so far this may look
like some pretty
common standard moves from bow side
especially in the french defense but
this is
a huge mistake for black because white
has the move
bishop takes here on h7 and this
is the greek gift sacrifice that we're
looking at right here and we'll kind of
look at the reasons
uh that this is extremely bad for black
how
white can attack this if they take this
bishop if they don't take this bishop as
well so the first one we're going to
look at is if they take this bishop here
on h7
and then we can play knight to g5
now there's two things that this
knight's doing here on g5 one it's
attacking the king yes
but it's also opening up the door for
the queen to come here to h5 and that's
going to be
critical this knight is also being
defended by the bishop here on
c1 so that black can't just take with
the queen here on g5 that would lose
the queen so from here king comes back
here to
g8 queen to h5
you can still see they can't take with
their queen we could just recapture with
our queen
or our bishop so maybe instead
they recognize that the next move is
going to be queen here 2h7
that's going to be checkmate and so
maybe they play something like rook 2e8
trying to give their king another place
to go
but now that rook here on f8 was
protecting
this square here on f7 white's now free
to take
on f7 this is not going to end well it's
going to end in a checkmate after king
2h8
queen comes back here to h5
king g8 queen up here h7 and then there
is a checkmate
pretty soon after that
so that was the example if they take the
bishop here on h7 it is going to end
extremely bad for them they're either
going to give up their queen
or they're going to lose the game very
quickly the only other option they have
is to play king 2h8
same thing from white they're gonna play
knight to g5 now this is not check
so they do have that going for them as
far as black not being under
immediate threat but they still have to
worry about
the queen coming here to h5 on the next
move so
if they start to look at how can black
defend against this they could think
that maybe bishop here to e7 does
something it attacks the knight here on
g5 now they have the bishop and the
queen here on
d8 but this doesn't matter too much
because
the knight takes here on f7 and this is
check
and this is also attacking the queen
here on d8 so if they decide you know
what i'm just gonna take this bishop
okay y just takes the queen and the game
is
completely lost for black once their
queen is gone
and if they don't take the bishop here
on h7
maybe they decide let's let's take that
knight here on
f7 well now queen two h5
preparing to move the bishop there will
be a discovered attack here not a lot of
great ways to protect against this
maybe knight to f6 trying to open up
something
giving up some material but after the
pawn takes here
bishop takes then bishop to g6
check king is forced to move here to g8
and after the bishop takes it's
protected by the queen here as well
king over here to f8 bishop to g6
and things are lost for black
so that was if they play bishop here to
e7 they don't have to play that they
could try something else maybe g6 all
these are going to
be bad moves there's just nowhere for
black to run after the greek give
sacrifice here on
h7 maybe pawn two g6 is an
effort here and yes that does stop the
queen coming here to h5 but everything
is so blocked off from black here you
can see
none of these pieces bishop here on c8
knight on b8
rook on a8 can really get involved into
the game
this knight here on a d7 is pretty
locked out can't come to f6 it just dies
immediately
bishop here on b4 is completely out of
the game and the queen has a hard time
getting involved into the game it can
it can try just coming here to e7
but it doesn't do a whole lot and so
white has a lot of time that even if
they don't come to queen h5
they can just come to queen to g4
knowing that the next move queen to h4
puts a lot of pressure on their opponent
and maybe they try to get their queen
involved into the game because
there's no other options here queen to
e7 can't come to queen to f6
because it just falls to the pawn here
but then
maybe just queen two h3 this is still a
discovered attack if
the bishop moves right here so maybe
they
get their king out of the way king 2g g7
but then knight 2 e4 and this is a nice
little move here because it prepares
if they ever need to uh to get the
knight up here to f6
it opens up the door for the dark script
it should get involved into the game and
the pawn can't take it right here
because that would lose the game
immediately
this bishop is protected by the queen
the queen is protected by the bishop
here on c1
this is check king comes back here to h8
and then a very quick
checkmate from here so if we come back
after the move knight to
e4 we could see
uh some other effort that's just not
going to go
extremely well like where do they
actually move here they can't come to
king 2 f6 uh they can't
come up here to h8 it's going to be a
qui pretty quick checkmate after bishop
takes here
on g6 with the discovered attack uh they
can't really get their knight involved
into the game because the pawn can take
it as well as
the knights they can always exchange
here on c3
but that's just delaying time none of
their pieces can really get involved
into the game
so white can pretty much sit back and do
whatever they want to with a very strong
attack
with the threat of queen to h6 on the
next move because remember
that is defended by the bishop here on c
one so that is the greek greek gift
sacrifice hopefully you guys enjoy this
also that
sacrifice here on age seven if you're
curious
when can white sacrifice their bishop
here on h7 and when can they not because
it's not always an option for you
sometimes it can go extremely poorly
i will have a link at the end of this
video
that will detail exactly what you should
be looking for it's a video i made a
while back but tells exactly the setup
that you should be looking at
to know when you can actually take this
pawn here on h7
and when you cannot so definitely if you
like this and you think that this is
something that may come up in your game
i highly recommend watching that video
as well it's gonna make a lot more sense
around
why this works and why you may see it
often in your games
uh so definitely check that out thank
you guys so much for watching the video
i'll see you guys next time
you